Eric what's the salutary role for
skepticism and do you see Mick as being
a proponent of that
I'm confused by Mick and I don't
understand Mick but consider that I
really haven't been out here for very
long
in UFO territory
um it's not a region of the world uh the
intellectual landscape that I expected
to visit or spend any time in so as of
I don't know two years ago I was pretty
much the guy who shut down every UFO
conversation that people wanted to have
around me
um
and so that was sort of my role in my
own intellectual set
and then
um I came to believe that
clearly I had been the target
of myths and disinformation from all
sides
and then it became this question of well
what the hell is this topic if it's not
what I thought it was
and I guess I've been very surprised to
have
um
encountered Mick in the Twitter sphere
so I don't think of him as particularly
gunning for me or out out to get me but
there is some aspect of
he's he sees himself in a role
um with respect to
a community which and let me just say
the the positive part of this there's a
lot of complete nonsense in UFO land
that
is not only false but is also bunk in
the sense that somebody a Bunko artist
needed to create the bunk in order for
the bunk to exist it's not a question if
somebody saw a mylar balloon and got
confused
so there's really a role for debunking
and in particular I think there's a role
for debunking aimed at our government
because clearly the government has been
up to Bunk either then or now or both
but it can't be neither there has to be
some aspect of this that is bunk
where I get very confused is for those
of us who have never particularly
focused on an incident or a set of
people or
group of names I mean
I am very confused as to what Mick is
trying to police
um because at the moment I'm just saying
like I'm confused and apparently
somehow it's not good enough to be
confused one must also be clear that
this is nonsense and I'm not at all
clear that this is not so
well you're confused about me I can
maybe I can clear up what my position is
what I'm actually trying to do here and
partly is I'm not really trying to do
anything yeah the I got into this this
this field simply as a hobby
I originally started investigating
debunking the Chemtrails conspiracy
theory like over 10 years ago after I I
left the the video game industry and I
had a lot of spare time on my hands and
I was like learning to fly and doing
things like that and it was just very
interesting to me and it was like
essentially a series of puzzles
and people say like why do you spend so
much time on this well I kind of respond
to that with uh some people have hobbies
some people spend it in Northern
inordinate amount of time on things like
running model trains or painting little
figurines or making funny dolls or
skydiving or whatever whatever the hobby
happens to be and this this topic here
like investigating things happens to be
something that really intersected with
my my skill set of debugging things like
figuring things out what's the root
cause the root cause analysis sort of
things and my interest in science I've
always been interested in Popular
Science and so it's just something I
just kind of got sucked into and it kind
of spread out and you know eventually I
kind of settled down in a way on this
UFO thing because
it's so interesting in terms of the
mathematics the geometry and the physics
you know very simple physics you know
just simple Newtonian stuff linear
algebra and things like that it's
nothing complicated but it's stuff that
I I used in my previous career and so I
kind of enjoy flexing those muscles and
recently I've been enjoying flexing my
muscles programming simulations uh and
yeah I do also enjoy the interactions
with people I like talking to people I
like talking to people who believe and
people who used to believe and you know
to a certain degree talking to Skeptics
although you know to be honest a lot of
the Skeptics are you know rather the
grumpy boring types that you know don't
have a lot of fun and the UFO people are
much more fun best fun I ever had was uh
the Flat Earth conference I went to
there was a real party but yeah I'm I'm
not
trying to do anything huge here
perhaps in the broader sense of
debunking conspiracies I want to make
the world a better place by having fewer
conspiracies out there but the vast
majority of what I do it's like oh an
interesting UFO video let's have a look
at it or you know this guy said
something let's see if it checks out you
know it's it's kind of like this this
fun hobby that ends up touching on
things that might be fairly important
well it gives us a great deal of insight
so let me just to mix it up with you
um say you've mentioned chemtrails
and you've mentioned Flat Earth
and you've mentioned UFOs and the fun of
interacting with people and debunking
and making the world a better place and
I think I'm starting to see the outline
of where this problem occurs
so
the key issue in a lot of these things
is type 1 versus type 2 error chemtrail
sounds pretty stupid and to be honest
Little Green Men seems pretty dumb to me
too
to say nothing of the Flat Earth which
seems idiotic and preposterous
but if you ask me the idea of the
Tuskegee medical experiment and
untreated syphilis sounds dumb oh really
the government's going to allow people
to go untreated into tertiary syphilis
or
we're actually going to kill Fred
Hampton in his bed through cointel Pro
using the Cook County Sheriff's
Department or we're going to trade
you know drugs for arms with Iranians in
the Iran Contra all of these things
sound dumb to me
because they're clearly preposterous
and the concern that I have is that I
don't believe in ghosts and I don't
believe in the Loch Ness Monster
and I do believe in J Edgar Hoover's FBI
as an agent
agency you know filled with evil
targeting ordinary Americans for their
political beliefs up to and including
their personal destruction and death
including using
are free press to plant stories and
Destroy people
and so I imagine you in all of these
contexts
and I imagine you as the guy who said oh
really you think the FBI is going to
come up with a story and plant it in the
Los Angeles Times that Gene seberg has
been a leading actress has been
impregnated and cuckolded
um her husband with a leading black
panther yeah tell me another one Eric
except that really happened
and this is where I start to get into my
issue which is
I really don't like the personal
destruction of individuals who are
trying to sort out fact from fiction and
type 1 versus type 2 error an incredible
and Preposterous stories that are
clearly not true and incredible and
Preposterous stories that are absolutely
true
and the debunking energy of this is fun
it's a hobby it's a Pastime with other
people on the other side of this who are
not bunco artists
uh who've come to believe things some of
those things may be completely false
some of those things may be
um
confusions
some of those things may be true and
we're going to call them false because
they're actually part of the storyline
for example you could easily imagine in
the UFO case that we would use a UFO
cover story to disguise the testing of
stealth technology before anyone knew
that we were working on it and if so if
I see a giant black wedge in the sky
that looks like no airplane ever
um you know and was thin as a pancake uh
I would be needing in need of debunking
simply because the government had
created a Bunko story I had seen
something and then I had to be
personally destroyed in order to make
sure that the program stayed Secret
so I guess I I to be blunt about it I
see this as punting the responsibilities
of a human being a scientist and a
skeptic to take a side in this it's like
the really difficult time thing is
decision boundaries type 1 versus type 2
errors trying to figure out who's active
in trying to Bunk things that needs to
be debunked who's confused who needs to
be made unconfused and who is saying
that they're seeing something that needs
to be followed up and not necessarily
having their reputation destroyed
because somebody wants to in your own
words Flex I don't find the flexing fun
and to be able to say Flex you did say
Flex
I don't well it's not a word I actually
use so uh I'd say something about
flexing your own oh flexing my muscles
but it's not like Flex as in like you
know
complexity yes I know but uh for me
flexing actually means the same thing as
stretching right okay but right now I
just went through exactly one of these
moments where I tried to remember
something you'd said and then you told
me that you don't use that as a phrase
and I happen to be able to call it in a
sense the sense that you mentioned no
yeah
I think you did say it in the original
sense from which the the internet term
Flex comes from so I don't think that's
even correct so my point to you is I
don't enjoy the feeling in my body right
now which is I've just contradicted you
you assured me that that's not a term
that you use
we had yeah perhaps at most
misunderstanding
but
but the feeling of somebody saying no
you're wrong and thinking that that's
fun your initial description of your
activities is a hobby I don't much care
for this as a hobby if it's a duty
because the world is going to be filled
up with nonsense I actually appreciate
that I want to be very clear about that
but the fun of interacting with people
many of whom
are scared
I've seen people close to and filled
with tears I've seen people who feel
that their lives have been destroyed
because they have made contact with
something that they can't talk about me
too and I wouldn't be very clear here
like I'm not doing that for fun when I
talk to people uh and I have a podcast
uh tells from the rabbit hole where I
talk to people who are you know
Believers or experiences or whatever and
I'm very respectful and I I think the
vast majority of people who who are in
that position who are very upset you
know there are people who you know have
developed serious uh emotional issues
because of their experiences and that's
something I very much respect and I I
certainly would not in in any sense say
I'm having fun uh debunking that in fact
there's some people that I I prefer not
to even talk to because I know that they
are they are so sensitive when I'm
talking about fun I'm talking about
things like geometry and programming and
figuring out what's in this video and
those things should be things that are
essentially neutral from a personal
perspective I know some people don't
like it but I I try to always keep that
personal aspect of it separate I enjoy
talking to people uh just simply from
the interactions with people but I'm
always very sensitive to people's
feelings I haven't enjoyed our
interactions
uh well that's that's perhaps you know
my my interaction style could do with
some improvements but you know when I
said mine could as well and I look
forward to improving I haven't blocked
you I'm just saying that the feeling
I've had
is I was effectively lied to that there
was absolutely no there there
I believed it
what are you referring to uh the idea I
thought that in essence the entire UFO
um story could just be dismissed with
the back of a hand that this is complete
nonsense
in a sense on that uh that's aspect of
it I think that the UFO story is
something that needs investigating and I
think what we have here is something I
think that perhaps you have been doing
here is kind of simplifying a very
complex subject down into like you know
it's either one thing or the other uh
like you would you would you were
describing my um you know debunking as
as you know some some kind of you know
calling I can't remember exactly what
you said but uh I think you were kind of
describing it to the very high level you
know as if what I am doing is trying to
prove that little green men don't exist
and that all these people are wrong
uh when I look at data I look at it kind
of the micro level uh where I am looking
at individual cases I'm trying to figure
out what's actually going on in this
individual case now if someone asked me
my opinion about the broader uh
implications of this then I'll give that
but that's not my goal that's not what
I'm actually trying to do uh when you're
describing you know what I'm doing
you're describing like as if I have some
kind of big agenda trying to you know
debunk UFOs as a whole
really I'm just looking at individual
things okay look
I think if you look before two years ago
you'll find no discussion you know I
discuss almost everything under the sun
zero discussion of UFOs okay
I don't think I have any particular
history of oh didn't you understand in
the in the go fast video of this but on
the Nimitz video you know such and such
in favor said this and but Lazar said
that like this whole world I'm just not
even a part of
uh I know that there's somebody with the
last name of Greer I couldn't tell you
the first name I don't know whether
they're Pro or Auntie it's like I'm
really not part of this world
sure um what I have learned is
that the amount of indirect evidence
that something is up and something I
have to say when I don't when I say
something I don't mean little green men
and I mean little green men not as
little or green or men but just as the
phrase to uh aliens yeah
it's like
what could be up could easily be just a
disinformation campaign it could be a
cover for us a stealth program it's
there's something up and
I don't need to please you to tell you
what weights are on the on the branches
of the decision tree I simply need to
say boy was I confused this isn't just a
bunch of people seeking attention
uh or some sort of promo stunt for a
Spielberg film gone wrong it's
it's quite a bit larger than that it's a
tremendous amount of indirect evidence
that the basic puzzle as I understand it
and again I'm I'm new here
um is that there is zero convincing
direct evidence where there's a chain of
custody with the data
um
and you know we it's not only a question
of a few seconds of video but you know
very detailed multiple sensor data
everything sort of fits in in some kind
of a way that you could actually say
there's no there's essentially no way of
Faking this yeah there's almost none of
that
to my knowledge there is no convincing
proof in the public sphere
so that's the big thing that argues for
the fact that this is not about UFOs or
um in the sense of uh aliens and Little
Green Men and sentient intelligence
that goes in the other direction though
is just how much indirect evidence there
is that something has been going on
and
how willing we've been to destroy people
who've been willing to poke at this
and
if you believe that the direct evidence
argument is effectively a pretty good
argument that nothing's here because so
many of us have cameras it's kind of
amazing that nobody ever captures
something that's really really
convincing
um that doesn't make sense to me if you
believe that story you've got a big
problem with the level of indirect
evidence if you believe the indirect
evidence you have the reverse problem
for God's sakes why is there no
absolutely crystal clear
uh data set that has slipped into the
Public's hands so whatever your
resolution to that puzzle is
I'm usually in the position where I come
up with too many explanations this is
one of the only topics I've ever met
where a creative brain can't come up
with a single explanation to fit all
these data points
well I think the reason for it is that
there isn't a single explanation and I
think it's a mistake to try to look for
one I think there's a lot of things that
explain both the actions of government
and the military and the various
interested part is like you know to the
Stars Academy and people like that
and there's a variety of explanations
for the sightings that people are having
the evidence the that arises and trying
to kind of shoot on it into either you
know one big cluster or one big cover-up
uh perhaps there's a degree of both in
that perhaps the government does use
things like UFO stories to allow them to
be out there at least for distractions
from other things and certainly like we
know that there's a variety of different
interesting parties within the
government there are there's infighting
there's there's a degree of incompetence
uh which I think you know is kind of
endemic anywhere there's corruption uh
there's kind of you know there's back
dealing those people who are doing
things for their friends in government
and there's a variety of things and I I
think it's not going to be simple if we
actually figure out you know what's
going on with this whole UFO thing I
think you're going to be looking at you
know hundreds and uh maybe thousands of
different data points that and there
won't be like one big Smoking Gun either
way wait a second let's just take one
category of UFO things so we have mylar
balloons and swamp gas and
disinformation campaigns and
experimental aircrafts and drones and
and then
non-friendly Nations blah blah blah
let's just take everything that is a
normal sounding explanation that can
account for this and and let's take
various claimed UFO encounters
and
attribute those to those explanations
that we're all prepared to accept
include some of the sightings
or experiences is there anything left
over in your opinion that's really
unsettled
because it's a question of overlapping
explanations for like it could be the
Chinese or it could be the Russians or
it could be the Iranians or it could be
swamp gas
it's like I get that those are all the
same style of explanations I mean if if
the the government says they have 143
unsold or 142 now they just said they
were the chief scientists just said they
solved one yesterday uh but they those
are actually cases that are unsolved
that they were unable to determine what
they actually are and the likely
explanation is simply that there isn't
enough data so there's definitely going
to be lots of interesting things out
there uh they probably fit into one of
the the categories of things like
Airborne clutter or atmospheric effects
or heavenly bodies or planes or
misidentifications things like that but
we can't determine what they actually
are but what we don't have is what you
said earlier we don't have something
that's unambiguously uh unusual
something that demonstrates Advanced
aerodynamic capabilities or something
that seems to defy the known laws of
physics but we certainly have lots of
unresolved things
that necessarily means anything I think
that's that's just something that's
inevitable and I think that when we have
here more detailed inspections of data
sets it's just going to it's going to
resolve more thing not resolve it's
going to bring up things like that RV
loeb's new program the project Galileo
program he's is trying to set up these
telescopes and these sensors which will
detect when something's there and then
they'll zoom in on it and then they'll
take photographs of it and he says maybe
they'll see the you know made in uh um
made in outer space sticker on it but
probably what's going to happen is just
you're going to get more blurry photos
and they will be undetermined so
it's inevitable you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy